words you won't use in recipes yes I
basically banned words and then I made
the whole editorial team agree and sign
to never ever but now some of them I
understand but there's a list of them
this is the list of the banned words now
moist I know I know you mean but some
things some recipes yes should be they
all have reason I mean do you ever need
crevice well yeah because if you're
stuffing like a shoulder of lamb and you
want to really get it into the crevice
if you say crevice but crevice and
dinner doesn't really work as does
and is
really important in pastry work because
you're yeah because you have to give it
a good to to get the pastry oh
my
[Applause]